frenetic l'une d'elles la tâche le vieux
maréchal des logis élus furieux mort aux
vaches mort aux lois vive l'anarchie
mort aux vaches mort aux lois vive
l'anarchie voilà ce que chantait georges
brassens avec délectation en 1972 la
chanson s'appelle hécatombe écrite en 52
elle raconte le combat picaresque entre
les femmes du marché de
brive-la-gaillarde et la maréchaussée
complètement débordée par les événements
cette ville et blanc se ruaient aussi
les guignols et d'honneur je vous la sur
un spectacle assez croquignol cette
chanson qui fut aussi l'occasion pour
brassens mine de rien de mettre quelques
takeo forces de l'ordre
en voyant ces braves pandores être à
deux doigts de succomber au péché car je
les adores sous la forme de macchabées à
sa sortie la chanson sera censurée sur
les ondes du service public mais elle
deviendra un classique et sera souvent
reprises comme ici par en haut est dit
qu'une des la tâche de maréchal des
logis débit fait crier mort aux vaches
mort aux lois vive l'anarchie
ou comme ici par jean bonnefon et
francis cabrel une autre four avec ruud
ainsi le crâneur dessus lourde entre ces
gigantesques feux ce cas là c'est
une chanson truculente et inoffensive
mais pas pour tout le monde en 2009 à
cherbourg des policiers ont arrêté un
homme qui chantait hécatombe à sa
fenêtre l'insolent sera condamné deux
ans plus tard 40 heures de travaux
d'intérêt général et 100 euros d'amendé
pour chacun des deux policiers outragés
la nouvelle se répandait dans tout le
pays et la réaction fut savoureuses
comme dans une chanson de brassens
d'aller en appel qu'à circuler là sur
internet a chanté un peu partout dans
les lieux de pouvoir à toulouse à paris
à quimper ou à auxerre en cet été 2011
des chorales improvisés ont défié la
police et la justice en chantant
hécatombe devant leurs locaux
et entre deux chansons les
protestataires venus clamer leur radio
version comme ici à auxerre quand la
chanson française qui est tellement
quelque chose d'important dans notre vie
qui est le reflet d'un peu de nous mêmes
on commence à l'interdire alors je me
dis bon les libertés sont vraiment en
danger et plus en danger qu'avant à
toulouse ce rassemblement de mélomanes a
conduit à quelques interpellations comme
quoi chanté hécatombe amène au violon
sauf heureusement à brive la gaillarde
car ici la chanson est un hymne au local
intouchable
[Musique]